why have you decided to come as a lady
Doki and lady saw today because we're in
love with three Avengers so we kind of
decided well let's do genderbent version
so our own interpretation not be a
phonological gender and what is it about
loki that appeal so much i just really
like the type of villain he is just it's
my favorite i'm revealing the sarcasm
that mental which is the magics just my
favorite type of character and did you
love him both in saw the movie and in
the Avengers as well yeah very much so
now what would you like to see happen in
thoughts who do you think that's tricky
I'd like to see four reunite with James
I think that would be nice let me just
going to draw some Avengers but yeah and
I want low key to being it obviously to
be kind of like the villain but with a
sense that you can still be redeemed
what would you like to see like he gets
a pretty much a reconciliation scene for
Loki and Thor because Thor just cares so
much about locum they just need another
brother link sort of bond again
definitely know guys it's tell me about
picking these costumes together because
they believe they're quite impressive a
birthday uh well the horns that are
basically wire and lots and lots of
paper mache and they so many layers just
took absolutely ages but they're working
quite well I think they seem to be yeah
they seem to have gone down quite well
yeah bit painful but worth it how they
kind of kept on your head it's like a
band doesn't attach them to a headband
and then I've got a lots to run the
backs keeper in place they do they feel
quite heavy or sort of heavy but not too
much it's okay I like tell you about the
rest the outfit so you going for the
Loki look I just went to loads of shops
to found the dress and then went through
a lousy jobs fine jewelry that would
match and store
just that anything that would go and I
seem to do quite well with that what
were you basing on one of the particular
looks in particular like the film or the
comic version pretty much and how about
you lady Thor
yeah well the headpiece is actually a
headband with craft foam gems glued on
and then just a bunch of feathers stuck
onto cards hot glued on the dress is a
dress I found perfect
maybe cave family gone that's okay man
just put the boots together
oh well I cheated this I bought from
Expo in May so it's like the official
prop hammer so yeah she is a better prop
maker of me so yeah I didn't fancy
making her then what kind of if you're a
good prop maker what kind of tips and
tricks you got for those cosplayers we
did to be honest just persevere with it
I guess I mean I'm pretty much a
beginner if this is like the first major
thing I've done so yeah just persevere
and don't give up and don't get angry at
it which I did it's very impressive I
would never known as a first attempt -
how about you you've been cosplaying
before yeah I've been cosplaying since
2010 so yeah usually I do more anime
characters but this year I've kind of
found my niche in comics now I want to
carry on doing this future cosplay
outfits what are you thinking of miss
Marvel cause loads Captain America
female version USO girl I'm doing
annoying net dance of my man - in August
so how about you I really like to do
Lady SIF at one point maybe for October
that's gonna be my aim anyway well good
luck with that guys and enjoy the rest
of the comic-con
you
you